[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en 324 este es un
magacín informativo 100% dedicado al
continente africano pero liviana
valencia aquí damos una mirada en
profundidad los hechos de actualidad de
la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
el presidente de túnez caixa y el
decidió ampliar el estado de excepción
que el mismo decreto hace un mes cuando
removió de su cargo al primer ministro y
congeló el parlamento hay preocupación
entre los opositores por una denominada
purga anticorrupción iniciada por el
mandatario
falleció en dakar la capital de senegal
el expresidente de chad y se abre a los
79 años durante su mandato entre 1982 y
1990 se vivió un régimen que se cobró la
vida de miles de personas y que luego lo
llevó a ser condenado por crímenes de
lesa humanidad la relación entre argelia
y marruecos pasa por un nuevo momento de
tensión
argelia anunció lo que consideró como
acciones hostiles por parte de marruecos
y rompió relaciones con la nación
estos vencidos mantienen un conflicto
fronterizo de larga data tenemos
reportes desde marrakech
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días porque un mes
después de tomar la decisión de
suspender al parlamento y de destituir
al primer ministro el presidente de
túnez cádiz ayer anunció la extensión
del estado de excepción éstos mientras
el país sigue sumido en una difícil
crisis económica y sanitaria por otro
lado el presidente inició una purga anti
corrupción que ha despertado temores por
posibles ataques a las libertades en el
país norteafricano
por ahora no habrá restablecimiento de
la normalidad democrática en túnez así
lo confirmó al presidente de caixa side
un mes después de tomar una decisión que
provocaría críticas de la comunidad
internacional y también apoyo de
sectores importantes de la población
este es el comunicado oficial
el presidente de la republica caixa ayer
emitió una orden presidencial ampliando
las medidas excepcionales esas medidas
fueron implementadas por caixa site el
25 de julio cuando anunció la suspensión
del parlamento y la destitución del
primer ministro
adoptado ron howard la primera decisión
es congelar todos los poderes del
parlamento la constitución no permite su
disolución pero no obstaculice la
suspensión de todas sus actividades
partidos políticos y organizaciones
denunciaron las medidas así como parte
de la comunidad internacional
mientras muchos tunecinos exasperados
con su clase política recibieron con
entusiasmo la decisión del presidente
con respecto a esta decisión es la
primera vez en mi vida que escucho a un
jefe de estado tomar una decisión
correcta
hemos recuperado nuestro país es la
primera vez que salgo a la calle a
celebrar en paralelo el jefe de estado
inició una purga anticorrupción con
arrestos y prohibiciones de viaje- a
magistrados diputados y empresarios lo
que suscitó preocupaciones de un
retroceso de las libertades en el país
caixa side aún no ha designado un nuevo
gobierno ni desvelado su hoja de ruta un
mes después la confusión sigue en el
país mientras el presidente mantiene
todo el poder hasta nueva orden
falleció a los 79 años el expresidente
ya se sabe quién es fuera el primer jefe
de estado en haber sido condenado por
crímenes contra la humanidad por una
corte africana ave murió en hospital de
dakar senegal después de haberse
contagiado de kobe 19 según medios
locales fue presidente de chad entre
1982 y 1990 en un régimen que dejó miles
de personas asesinadas y torturadas pero
con fuertes nexos también con occidente
fue condenado a cadena perpetua en 2016
pero sólo cumplió cuatro años entre las
rejas
en 1982 x en auge tomó el poder por las
armas y se convirtió en el tercer
presidente de chad un régimen que
comenzó marcado por la represión
sus detractores ya fueran verdaderos
opositores o sospechosos de serlo fueron
arrestados y después torturados detrás
de los muros de esta edificación yacen
los recuerdos de años de sufrimiento y
martirio así misma él fue encerrado en
este calabozo dice será una de las
varias víctimas de la tiranía de hitn
abre así lo recordaba él mismo de vuelta
al lugar
donde estábamos en celdas pequeñas de
tres metros por cuatro que no podían
albergar más de diez personas pero las
que estábamos hasta 27 serie avance hubo
muchos muertos aunque la impresión que
su amor
una comisión de investigación cifraría
posteriormente en más de 40.000 los
fallecidos o ejecutados bajo el mandato
de aguirre en 1990 uno de sus antiguos
generales ido hey débil lo sacó del
poder
reacio a abandonar el país y se nave
encontró refugio senegal en donde vivió
de manera tranquila por más de 20 años
pero en 2011 el presidente abdoulaye
wade sorpresivamente decidió que ya no
era bienvenido dicen haber arrestado el
30 de junio de 2013 en dakar y después
en 2016 condenado a cadena perpetua por
un tribunal especial de la unión
africana
argelia rompió relaciones diplomáticas
con marruecos citando lo que calificó
como acciones hostiles de su vecino la
medida sigue a un periodo de tensión
creciente entre los países que están
sumidos en una disputa de larga data con
sus fronteras cerradas entre sí una
relaciones que se deterioraron aún más
en las últimas semanas cuando el
embajador de marruecos en la onu dijo
que la gente de la región
independentista de cabilia en argelia
debería tener derecho a determinar su
estado futuro un hecho que se sumó a una
lista de conflictos como la decisión de
marruecos de entablar relaciones
diplomáticas con israel a cambio el
reconocimiento de la soberanía marroquí
sobre los territorios que ocupa desde
1975 en el territorio del sahara
occidental por este tema hablamos con
nuestra corresponsal es marruecos o
sofía catalán que nos amplía la
información
sería hecho oficial la ruptura de sus
relaciones con marruecos y con esto se
abre un nuevo capítulo en el conflicto
que los regímenes de ambos países
vecinos mantienen desde hace medio siglo
por imponer su influencia sobre el sahel
y áfrica occidental y el propio gobierno
de marruecos
calificó a desesperada esta ruptura que
se veía venir desde que marruecos
normalizar a sus relaciones con el
estado de israel a cambio del
reconocimiento
estadounidense de la soberanía marroquí
sobre el sáhara occidental y de hecho a
la ruptura se ha hecho oficial poco
después de la visita del ministro de
exteriores israelí yair lapid aquí en
marruecos donde criticó duramente
también al régimen argelino y el
ministro de exteriores de argelia señaló
también como motivos de la ruptura el
supuesto apoyo de marruecos al
movimiento independentista de kábila
comunidad masiva en el norte de argelia
y también a la supuesta implicación de
marruecos en el escándalo de espionaje
pegasus o por su parte el estado
marroquí ha calificó de falaces y
absurdas estas acusaciones
y la ruptura ante relaciones entre
argelia y marruecos se produce en un
contexto muy difícil para la región del
magreb y es que a las crisis políticas
que tienen lugar en argelia y túnez cabe
sumar el convulso proceso de paz que
atraviesa libia ahora también la
irrupción de israel en la región y una
crisis económica y sanitaria que no deja
de empeorar y por otra parte tras la
ruptura argelia marruecos está por ver
qué pasará con el gasoducto magreb
europa que desde 1996 transporta gas
argentino hacia la unión europea vía
marruecos
vamos ahora a senegal donde decenas de
adolescentes sueñan con ser jinetes
profesionales y así garantizarse un
mejor futuro un equipo periodístico de
france 24 visitó una escuela cerca de
dakar para mostrarnos la vida de estos
jóvenes lejos de la escuela
apenas tienen 10 años pero aquí están
con sus caballos galopando a través de
la arena senegalesa
niños los caballos representan la
esperanza de un futuro mejor
el entrenamiento comienza todos los días
al amanecer
babakar tiene 13 años este es su primer
año de entrenamiento
cuando montó a caballo soy feliz creo
que será más fácil para mí tener una
buena vida convirtiéndome en un jinete
que lleno la escuela un día tendré éxito
y ayudaré a mis padres
en senegal los jinetes ganan en promedio
el doble del salario de un funcionario
los niños se entrenan en este criadero
de caballos en los suburbios de dakar
son elegidos después de cumplir diez
años y deben pensar menos de 40 kilos el
entrenamiento es gratuito y a los niños
se les da techo y comida sin embargo no
hay escuela la gente aquí de muchas
carreras de caballos europeas son un
modelo e inspiran a la gente aquí
actualmente hay 20 niños inscritos aquí
pero me vio obligado a rechazar a otros
30 una vez
[Música]
el día de carreras y para babacar es tan
solo la segunda hasta ahora
suenan los tambores es hora de que todo
sencillo en sus caballos y compitan
[Música]
al principio iba de segundo luego un
caballo se adelantó
de bloqueo de la curva y todos me
adelantaron
yo gane hoy pero mañana será tu turno
todo ese trabajo duro que me trajo aquí
tú también tienes que hacerlo
cree en ti cree en este trabajo y lo
lograrás
es un largo camino para convertirse en
campeón
pero cada carrera despierta pasiones
crean nuevas ilusiones de convertirse
algún día en el número uno una chef
nacida en mozambique decidió radicarse
en colombia para dar a conocer el
continente africano por medio de la
gastronomía en total 24 hablamos con
silvana dufur y ella nos contó cuáles
son las principales influencias de la
cocina mozambicana y cómo ha sido
recibida por los comensales
latinoamericanos
hablar un poco tenemos también que
primero tenemos que explicar cómo son
unidades
entonces obviamente tenemos un poco la
gastronomía está también con
está en influencias de portadas de
comidas portuguesas también tenemos un
poco de influencia de asia india
entonces tenemos especialidad
y bueno tenemos lo fuerte estamos
mariscos que comemos muchos mariscos de
distintos institutos encontras acá el
campo lana y bueno la gastronomía es muy
rica muy rica
comemos muchos mariscos leche de coco
maní y frijoles
tenemos frutas ricas y algo más con
tenemos acá algunas tenemos donde el
objetivo es explicar un poco las
personas cómo vivimos
cómo
de la gastronomía
y finalizamos con música que nos llega
desde cuba uno de los países de américa
latina con mayor porcentaje de población
afro esta vez el reconocido productor y
cantante de yale lápiz se unió con el cp
para presentar su nuevo sencillo
titulado warriors
se trata de una canción que evoca el
espíritu de resistencia de los
descendientes de africanos en la isla
que han encontrado en la cultura y la
música justamente una forma de
reivindicación de sus raíces así
finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días pero los invitamos a
continuar con más en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom para emplear la
información de américa latina y del
mundo quédense con nosotros estos
france24
[Música]
y formó parte de un ejército que
representa la verdad el cual se nombra a
caballeros de la libertad es una
hermandad de soldados consagrados que
alcanzando grados han jurado defender el
rap por necesidad nuestra
responsabilidad es redimir valores que
han muerto en esta sociedad lo abrió
al llamar a frío
[Música]